Dentro de poco la bandera de Estados
Unidos volverá a flamear a mis espaldas
entre la de los 193 miembros de la
UNESCO la organización de Naciones
Unidas para la educación la cultura y la
ciencia después de dos días de asamblea
general extraordinaria este organismo
aceptado el plan de regreso del gigante
del Norte ha habido un voto mayoritario
a favor pero también quince abstenciones
y diez oposiciones entre ellas las de
China Rusia Siria o Irán los
diplomáticos rusos desde ayer habían
presentado varias enmiendas y también
declaraciones diciendo que los que
defienden la democracia luego quieren a
llevarlos a un Mundo paralelo con un
regreso con derechos a la medida y
privilegios Irán por su parte acusó a
Estados Unidos de violar por decirlo de
una manera la Constitución de esta
institución con este plan de regreso Lo
cierto es que Estados Unidos dejó la
UNESCO recordemos efectivamente en el
año 2018 fue una iniciativa de Donald
Trump que entre otros calificó
de anti israelita pero también desde el
año 2011 bajo el gobierno de Barack
Obama había dejado de pagar después de
la incorporación de Palestina al
organismo por lo tanto el plan de
regreso incluye ponerse al día con esas
cuotas atrasadas desde 2011 a 2018 es
decir 619 millones de dólares es más que
el presupuesto anual de UNESCO pero
también seguir aportando un 22% del
presupuesto es el mayor contribuyente de
la UNESCO y además hacer aportes
extraordinarios que Irán para proyectos
de Educación en África de memoria del
holocausto y defensa de los periodistas
los analistas ven este regreso a Estados
Unidos como una iniciativa del gobierno
biden después del fin de La era de
Donald Trump pero también como una
iniciativa de Estados Unidos para
intentar contrarrestar la influencia que
ha ganado china en este foro
concretamente en temas de tecnología e
Inteligencia artificial